hi everyone it's david here dennis is
going to be out of town for the next
couple weeks so i'm going to be here
filling in
talking about breaking bad this is
episode 12 from season five called rabid
dog another great episode another one
this episode just keeps building and
building like again i always say this i
know we talk about baroque empire we
talk about breaking bad in the show that
i don't i never want to say like nothing
happens because there's so much stuff
under the surface happening like a game
of thrones like all the great shows on
television again nothing like crazy
happen but at the same time there's just
something building and building you know
it's going to be this awesome finale
that's going to come in episode 8 or
episode 16 of the second half of season
5. so i guess the big thing to talk
about i don't know i mean i guess is the
the ending i think that's probably like
the biggest thing right now i mean it's
crazy jesse sees this big bald guy uh
you know kind of kitty corner to wall
and i just love that at the end you know
his little girl comes up coming home
from school like walt wasn't trying to
kill jesse that wasn't a hitman that was
just a guy waiting
to pick up his daughter so that was a
cool scene i mean it's just so much
stuff i mean now jesse wants to come
after him he's telling hank there's a
better way what do you think that's
going to be like i think it's going to
play out like you know i mean where we
know walt has to leave at some point i
mean where he's at like new hampshire
vermont way out there somewhere out in
the northeast so we know he's going to
have to leave uh
new mexico at some point like when's
that going to happen i think another
great revelation this episode another
just awesome scene is just seeing how
dark skyler's getting
part of me feels bad for anna gunn i
think i i've never been a huge fan of
the way vince gilligan has portrayed him
uh i portrayed her i'm sorry
she's she's either the nagging wife or
now she's like wants to just kill people
i'm like she's suggesting walt's crazy
on his own but now she's suggesting that
we need to like you know put him down
put jesse down and walt responds like
he's not some rabid dog i mean as far as
walt is from just being anywhere near
humane i don't know what's going through
walt's head i think he still does care
for jesse um i think the show should now
be called like let's see how elaborately
walt can lie i mean what he's doing with
like the stories he's telling about the
gasoline and how he got gas all over him
he's trying to pump his gas i mean it's
just the stories are crazy and they can
do a whole show
just on uh that alone but
i mean yeah i feel bad for anagon going
back to that i just
never a huge fan of the way they
portrayed her
i mean that she's the nagging wife and
like i said now she's just kind of the
crazy person who wants to kill people
wants to kill jesse i feel like vince
gilligan is writing the show you know
and looking at this man and the downfall
of man and i think it's coming from a
very male perspective even though there
are females in the show and i think only
recently he's trying to address that a
lot of people have complained about
skyler i like anna gunn i think she's a
great actress my issue is i'm just not
sure the way they're portraying her like
going from kind of nagging housewife
which i don't like women who next i
don't like i don't mean i don't mean to
say that i don't like women who nag like
women in general i mean women on tv i
love strong female characters one of my
favorite shows one of dennis's favorite
shows uh kristin roth we all love
battlestar galactica such strong female
characters in that show i'd like anna
gunn to be more like that i think i
think the way they're portraying it
feels like i don't know if gilligan and
his writing team know quite what to do
with anagun
and i just i just haven't been a big fan
of her character but i do like her more
now than i did in the first two seasons
i think now she's a little more
interesting i don't mind that she wants
to put a hit on jess i think that's kind
of fun even though i don't want to see
jesse die i love jesse if anybody has to
survive this show i hope it's jesse i
don't know what's going to happen but i
mean what do you guys think about i want
to start a conversation here like what
do you guys think about this week's
revelations what do you think about what
happened i mean i mean how did you like
the ending you know with uh jesse seeing
the big bald guy and then him you know
picking up his daughter from school and
it not being what he thought it was and
i mean jesse's just going crazy what do
you think about walt's elaborate
storytelling um you know we also got to
see you know walt's uh
sister-in-law you know go to uh you know
see her little psychological session
there with her psychiatrist that was
kind of interesting uh i like that jesse
is staying with hank at his house that's
pretty funny so this is so much good
stuff you can just tell us it's building
and building so when you ever hear
dennis and i say something about like
the show is not doing anything on a
week-to-week basis we don't mean that in
a bad way we just mean that everything
is kind of under the surface like a game
of thrones like a boardwalk empire stuff
is happening but it's not always like
this huge big action sequence at the end
that has to cap it off or a huge
cliffhanger it's just there's just very
subtle levels which is why i think this
is one of the greatest shows of all time
and one of the greatest one of my top
three shows on television now so as
always please let us know what you think
you know come check us out let's check
out our youtube page which is think hero
pro also come check us on our website at
thinkhero.com
we're also on twitter if you want to
talk to dennis and hear what he has to
say i'm on there as well you can check
us out it's uh think hero want to come
talk to me personally i'm at griffinde
and of course we have a facebook page
and that's facebook.com think hero fans
okay until next week i'm gonna see you
guys next week for the next review so be
sure to check out this next week and
we'll talk again